apa qu'est ce qui à ma puce
ce centre est bizarre
il se passe quelque chose tu te souviens
de ce qu'on te renseigner
et moi grillon à pied sur une petite
trop bizarre tout va bien je m'en sors
comme on sait qu est-ce qu à recommencer
si tu perds le contrôle qu'est ce que tu
dois faire ça va pas marcher c'est pas
un robot en dise est une enfant
qui a des émotions d'enfant complètement
imprévisible
charlie ça doit rester enfouis et doit
le réprimer notre devoir c'est de la
préparer notre devoir c'est de la
protéger
si la trappe ils vont le mettre en cage
sans lui
cobaye
on la verra plus jamais
qui veut m'attraper
nous avons un problème il faut le gérer
en toute l'éducation
ramener là moi
je sais ce que c'est que de vivre en
cavale petit plus poursuit il sont
d'une exceptionnelle journée
vd vous voulez l'utiliser
charlie fait paniquer
santé
lâcher la vampire
les unique en son genre
elle adorait
voir tu dois apprendre à s'en servir
tu ne dois pas le subir c'est toi qui
décide
c'est un seul moyen de contrôler
pas de devenir une jeune fille
erap en prison il arrivera joie
tu vas changer
où elle sera capable de provoquer une
explosion nucléaire sauf toi à trouver
par la seule force de sa volonté
le monde va s'effondrer
jamais utilisé était temps pour faire
balle au centre
contre les méchantes six jurés
confiance charlie
pas peur
je t'en prie je suis la portée des eaux
là
je veux faire de mal à personne
mais je crois que jamais ça